Speaker 1: We do have a voicemail number. It is
available to you 24 hours a day. The number is
two one nine two. David P.. You can call any
time. Some people leave 20 voicemails in a row.
And typically when that happens, they just
get deleted. We don't have the ability to
field that much material. But here
is someone who called in who has a
prediction about Merrick Garland, the midterms
and charges against Donald Trump. Take a listen.
Speaker 7: This is Jonathan in Los
Angeles. Please. Merrick Garland
is going to wait until after the midterms
to a lump to indict Trump and his cronies
to avoid any appearance of being political.
And in which case we're going to have a huge,
huge case of special elections across the country.
Speaker 1: I don't see that as likely, and there
are some folks emailing me about Trump indictments
where it's starting to sound a little bit like
this. I don't mean this to be insulting, but it's
sort of like the Trump people who were saying,
OK, before December 13th, this thing's going to be
overturned. Well, it's going to be before January
6th. It'll be by the inauguration. It'll be
by March, April, early summer, late summer,
Halloween, Thanksgiving. And like, it's just not
going to happen. I don't think Merrick Garland is
waiting for the midterms to indict Trump and his
cronies. I just don't see no evidence of that.
And unless, you know, Joe Biden's not
running for reelection, I mean, either way,
I think there is also a risk politically
to doing it after the midterms anyway.
So I just don't see that as a likely
scenario. But I would love to be wrong,
and I'm willing to have my mind changed
by the facts changing on the ground.
We have a tremendous bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about the average work day
work from home higher than ever during the
pandemic. Work day length longer than ever
during the pandemic. On average, people
are working an extra full hour a day.
We'll talk about it. Elon Musk has changed his
mind or Twitter has Elon Musk, after buying
a seven percent stake in Twitter, will not be
joining the Twitter board, and we will also talk
about a bill introduced by Democrats, which would
require employees be given time off to vote. Some
folks thought maybe you had that already, but not
in this way. So we're going to talk about all of
those stories on today's bonus show. I also want
to remind you The David Pakman Show Town Hall one
week from today, 6:00 PM Eastern on April 19th.
It'll be streaming live on the Pacman Live YouTube
channel. That's not the main YouTube channel.
That's the other YouTube channel, Pacman Live.
Everybody is welcome to participate.
And lastly, you can now gift memberships
at Join Pacman dot com. If you have a
membership already great. We have almost
700 people waiting for free memberships. You
can sign up and check that this is a gift box,
and we'll give a membership to someone who's
waiting. Join Pacman dot com. Place to do it.
We'll see you on the bonus show or otherwise.
Unidentified: I'll see you back here tomorrow.